Joanne,
writing poetry as being down on your
hands and knees with the language.
Um,
you know,
if someone carbs a swans and animals out
of soap and that person loves soap.
And if you right,
you love the language.
So it's an opportunity.
Writing a poem is an opportunity to get
as close to the language has pretty much
you can get.
Um,
the other joy because it is a pleasure
and I,
I wouldn't,
I have no high mission that drives me to
write poetry.
It is a very hedonistic activity and I
get,
I write it for pleasure,
I go there to get pleasure and uh,
and if possible to give pleasure.
Um,
so,
uh,
one of the key pleasures is,
and most poets would,
would,
would agree with this,
it starting out not knowing where you're
going and finding a way to get there.
So the poem becomes
not a whole expression of something you
think or feel,
but it becomes a journey through itself
to an ending.
And that ending is a unforeseeable.
And in fact,
the ending is something that the poem is
busy creating.
It's almost as if the poem is the only
way to access that.
That particular ending.
Uh,
I have a poem called questions about
angels.
And at the end of that poem,
uh,
an angel appears and I didn't know she
existed before I write that wrote that
poem.
And I guess strictly speaking she
didn't.
So I think of that poem is simply the
job of that poem is to bring her into
being,
to bring its own ending into being.
When you're not writing,
there's an anxiety about whether you
will right again,
um,
of all the kinds of writers,
well,
at least compared to playwrights and
novelists,
poets return to the blank page more
frequently.
Um,
and you know,
a novel can take you six months or five
years to write,
but a poem,
you know,
can get done in an afternoon or a couple
of days,
um,
and then you're back to zero and you
have to restart from nothing.
And at that point,
the question comes up.
I mean,
can you restart?
Can you boot yourself up again,
so to speak?
Or was that ed?
Um,
so that,
that is probably the main anxiety I
think that goes with poetry writing is,
um,
heavier exposure to the blank page or
regular,
uh,
encounters with blankness.
I just go poem by poem.
I don't have an overarching,
you know,
sense of a book as a project.
I probably have a manuscript.
I do have a manuscript of foams that is
just about ready and I'm just,
you don't want to send it out too early.
It probably needs maybe two or three at
the most,
um,
really strong,
good poems and that it will be ready.
And so I'm just interested in getting
that out of the house and maybe starting
upon this afternoon or our next
Wednesday,
you know?
Oh,
great.